"No Time to Die" is all about endings, bringing
Daniel Craig's 15-year run as James Bond to a
close. It's a sprawling epic that's both
action-packed and tragic; it also does
something no Bond movie before it has ever done.
This is the ending of "No Time to Die" explained.
Every Bond movie has an extravagant villain with
an even more elaborate plan for world domination.
"No Time to Die" has new threat Lyutsifer
Safin, a megalomaniac with a grudge and
a peculiar worldview who thinks of
himself as a kindred spirit to Bond.
"License to kill… I could be
speaking to my own reflection."
Earlier in the film, Bond traces a Russian
scientist to a SPECTRE meeting in Cuba.
There, he discovers that Blofeld is
still running the shady organization
from behind bars through
the use of his bionic eye.
Blofeld attempts to use a bioweapon
that's been acquired from the scientist,
Orbuchev — a genetically targeted
virus made of nanobots called Project
Heracles — to kill Bond. But Orbuchev,
at the behest of his true boss Safin,
reverses the programming of the weapon to kill
every member of SPECTRE in attendance instead.
Safin saves Bond's life as he once did for
Madeleine Swann, Bond's estranged lover. When
Madeleine was a young girl, Safin sought revenge
against her father, Mr. White, for killing his
family. He killed Madeleine's mother but chose to
spare her life, a mercy he uses for leverage later
in the film to make her a pawn in his successful
plot to kill Blofeld and end SPECTRE forever.
Bond has been suspicious of Madeleine
since the film's opening scene,
when she led him into a trap at the grave of
Vesper Lynd. But Bond soon realizes the trap
was entirely Blofeld's plan to drive them apart.
Seeing that she has been used by outside forces,
Bond runs to Norway to find Madeleine,
and finds a big surprise awaiting him.
Five years pass in "No Time to Die" from the
film's harrowing opening breakup between Bond
and Madeleine to the main thrust of the story.
But when Bond reunites with Madeleine and
apologizes for the time they've lost while apart,
he discovers she has a daughter, Mathilde. Though
Madeleine initially insists he is not the father,
it is very clear she is not telling the truth.
After he meets his daughter, Madeleine
fills Bond in on her past with Safin,
how he saved her life and has
a strange obsession with her,
and how his parents used to be the
chief poison makers for SPECTRE.
Bond, with help from Q, is able
to track Safin to his base on
an island in murky international
waters between Russia and Japan,
where he is manufacturing Project Heracles on
a grand enough scale to deploy it globally.
But before Bond can embark on his mission
to kill Safin and stop Project Heracles from
spreading further, Safin and his men come
and kidnap Madeleine and their daughter.
Bond must infiltrate Safin's island
with the help of the new 007, Nomi,
while trying to avoid sparking an international
incident and causing even more trouble for MI6,
the agency that helped develop this
deadly weapon in the first place.
Bond and Nomi storm Safin's
base, neutralizing Orbuchev
and mowing their way through Safin's henchmen.
Bond is able to reunite with the kidnapped pair,
and also he now knows for certain
that one is indeed his daughter.
Nomi gets them off the island to safety so he
can get to the center of the base and disable
the blast door shielding that protects
Safin's operation from outside harm.
M is prepared to authorize a surgical strike of
missiles to destroy Safin's island and prevent
Project Heracles from being deployed, but it can't
be done until Bond destroys the defense system.
It's a suitably harrowing, nail-biting sequence,
complete with a ticking clock of inbound missiles.
But in his final altercation with Safin,
Bond is exposed to a version of the bioweapon
that's genetically locked to Madeleine's DNA.
In killing Safin, Bond dooms himself,
because if he makes it off this island
and comes into contact with Madeleine or his
daughter, he will infect and kill them both.
Resigned to his fate, Bond lowers
the island's defenses and says his
final goodbyes over comms to the love of his
life and the daughter he never got to know.
James Bond is dead. Long live James Bond.
Back at MI-6 headquarters. M eulogizes
Bond by sharing a drink with Nomi, Q,
Tanner, and Moneypenny. Over the course of the
last few films, each of these former colleagues
has developed their own meaningful rapport with
Bond, and the knowledge that he died saving the
world, cut off from a daughter he didn't even
know he had, weighs heavily on the entire group.
Elsewhere, Madeleine drives off into
the sunset with daughter in tow,
still struggling with loss. But looking at
her daughter, who she remarks has James' eyes,
she promises Mathilde to tell her a story. A
story about a man named Bond ... James Bond.
So what happens now?
"Do I look like I give a damn?"
James Bond has never died in a movie before,
despite 24 previous films full
of near-death experiences.
Because of the franchise's murky continuity,
none of the other Bonds' final outings were
creatively conceived that way. Up until "Casino
Royale" intentionally rebooted the series,
the first twenty movies essentially
followed the same James Bond.
But with "No Time to Die" being imagined
from the outset as Craig's final outing,
the filmmakers felt free to tell a story with
far more finality than any Bond movie before it.
But just because this Bond is dead doesn't
mean James Bond himself is being retired.
The last message in the credits echoes what so
many other Bond movies before it have promised:
"James Bond will return..." Not "007."
James Bond. That basically proves we'll
be getting another reboot of the
character in the next Bond movie.
Leading up to "No Time to Die," new entries in
the Bond franchise have elicited think pieces
about whether or not Bond can still
work onscreen in a changing world.
"Man talk."
"No Time to Die" proves you don't have to
drastically change Bond as a person — instead,
you need to change the world around him
and create drama out of that juxtaposition.
Whether the next take on Bond is
a drastic departure or a careful
refinement on what has come before,
the bold conclusion for "No Time to
Die" has set the stage for Bond to
endure. Here's to the next 25 movies.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about
Bond, James Bond are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.